i wanted to um
start the page 104 ton of anchor but uh
the book
tells you as much as i can
put in words
it took me two years to write it the
book so i had lots of time to think
about what i wanted to put and you
change it you think of something else
but uh it's
i'm pretty happy with uh you know the
content so
if you only have the book that's good
i'd like to talk to you about um
the way i see
aikido
i i haven't met anybody who's not a
stubborn person in life and
and sometimes we we listen to people but
we we don't quite agree with them and we
do our own thing
i'm no different and in aikido i
personally think a lot of uh i put a lot
of pegs in i won't go beyond
and i can say that now after all these
years of uh training in like you know
seeing lots of different teachers lots
of different styles
and
you know basically being happy with my
own
development and what i've arrived at
we're always a student we're always
trying to get better
but
i urge you to
try to think about certain principles
and sticking to them
now taina anchor
when i was a q grade going back many
years an english teacher gave me one of
the best pieces of advice that i'm going
to give you today
and that is
that
saito sensei seemed to make iwan waikido
to us very robotic and very mechanical
and it can make us
try so hard that we become stiff we
don't become flexible and we think that
um you know if i'm going to do time turn
the hanger
here you know
off of my arm
and then i do this and i i sort of go
around
we try so hard we become stiff
and um
we don't have freedom so what this
teacher said to me was best of advice i
i wouldn't at the time
uh move any more than the one movement
he showed so i kept trying to do the one
move and he exactly how he showed it
and he come at me and said tony if you
need to take a
an extra half a step
then take it
because
one day when you
find aikido
in your own body and make it your aikido
and you become natural
you're going to move about
and it'll be different
to how the set move is made
and i want to tell you this in time
so if you feel that you are trying so
hard that you feel stiff and like
trapped
please um remember those words
you've got to be as free as you can
and still get
the nice ton anchor
so going over the points that i remember
scentsy saying is don't show your
fingers because they can grab it so soft
fists
down they're down by your sides i'm
going to show you from different angles
you just offer your arm like this
you're off your arm like this
if you raise it anymore
and you try and hold it there you'll
feel that you're having to use strength
there's a place just there where it's
comfortable and that's now starting to
strain
all right
so this is comfortable
okay comes to you you don't go to them
if you do go to them
you just offer it
comfortably
it stays about
here
leveling your groin
it doesn't go
higher
if you have a window
reflection or mirror it's even better
i've put the joe down today to show you
[Music]
a line
so i'm standing here
you don't have to stand tight to the
line
your offer
comfortable
now i see a lot of teachers when they're
doing aikido and this will be going
perhaps against your thoughts but i
don't like um
the thought of going back into the uk
now if you do china anchor i'm going to
start at the
end of my joe you may not be able to see
it because of the light and everything
i offer
i
stimulate the fingers
i turn
this angle
should be the angle of their arm
i also believe in energy work
um you can't see it but
then coming
down on you
like this means they're committed
they're thinking
grip or
attack
attack so they're always thinking about
you know giving you
their best so it's like their energy is
coming towards you so when i
turn my fingers
i turn it and this is in the book the
angle of their arm i don't try and
make myself disformed disfigured you
know
so here
stimulate once i grab
turn the hand and really check on this
angle i i believe it's very important
halfway is no good too much is no good
the angle of their arm you can't see it
but you've got to guess it this angle
the book will show you the angles
you stand in
ikey posture
offer stimulate
angle
on the front foot before you shift the
weight so you're going to shift the
weight in a moment first you're going to
turn on the ball the front foot
the height of the hands
stay the same
as when you offered it
you can raise
you can
extend
these are
variations on the basic
all right so the basic is here
the the back leg doesn't want to be
locked out it wants to just be soft not
too soft some teachers they look like
they're sitting on a on a bar stool you
know
it shouldn't be like this
it should be the ken cut but not stiff
to locked back leg
okay when you look down over your knee
you should just see
your big toe and this joint this joint
here
you should about see this joint here
if you can see more then you've not gone
far enough if you can't see the big tone
you've got to look over yourself
then it's too much
detailed detail and more detail but not
stiffness
okay detail detail detailing not
the next point
you can't see yourself but this is up
white this is in the groin
a lot of people do this their upper body
starts to go over the line
i always say in my teaching
not to go backwards to go forwards
so
why would you go over here
if you're asking them to go please go
past
please go past you would step out the
way and say please go past psychosis
used to use this all the time
you offer you stimulate you direct you
don't go this does not move
any centimeters
this way you go around it
now this is where the english teacher's
words come into it when you turn
i'll stand away from the joke
when you turn don't let this go over but
adjust the front foot
there
adjust the front front there
you will find that this um
is about now moving to your best
position with comfort and ease don't
leave it there
sort of sense he was very verbal and he
would often
comment on other
stars
this is uh a yoshinkan style an aikid
kai a hombu style um
it's very stable and you will see
pictures of osensei doing this at times
but in the basic tanahenka
psychosense you said please
finish with the front foot straight
now why
you know why finish it here and not here
where you're very stable
because it's a basic
it's like the seed
you plant the seed you get the bush the
tree
so we're looking at the seed
why this if you have it here
if you try and go this way
now with your partner hanging on
you damage your own knee you put
pressure on your knee it's already got
pressure you add to it
if you're here you can go this way more
or that way more without
the pressure on your knee so this is the
benefit of
not doing this
in basic
okay not doing this in basic you can
only go this way with these you cannot
go that way without moving it
it takes an action
to move it just to there
so please try
this okay so what what have we got we've
got
handmade
offer
stimulate fingers
all of the front foot turns shift the
weight
don't go over here
adjust
the foot when you settle
off of the hand
the height of the groin
not too high
stimulate the fingers
shape
it comes in the tuck
turn as you shift the weight turn on the
ball of the foot
adjust the front foot
so this is all done in a smooth in a
in a smooth manner
hey
not locked not locked but just slightly
slightly soft
adjust adjust
i just
[Music]
adjust
don't let it get stuck
okay so this is the basic stages of
china henka
and with the book i hope all these
points would have had
check yourself check yourself in the
mirror check yourself in the shadow
this is
very important most people do it
naturally please try to avoid it
and try to be upright
so that when you have keep the thought
doors on
please go past
not
please go fast
okay
door's
roll we'll go on to the marotidori
next
but it's
everything is about
movement one last thought i just thought
of china anchor
let's move this
timer
if the person
is about a distance of about
50 centimeters away from my job
something that we do
step back and adjust okay
so we do turn and go back
but the aim in your tongue anchor in
your thinking should be a forward
thinking
not a
tighter backing not going back feeling
so it shouldn't be
it shouldn't be
here
going back back back back back
this thing
all right just keep checking the
distance
the feeling wants to be
the person who's coming to you so when
it's keenan agave
there's no good going back is there
because they're going to be going past
you you won't have anything to
extend you offer
stimulate
turn
sometimes you're off a little bit
with a
rest but
offer
this fight
stimulate
turn
and about here about in the middle like
my feet without my feet
the feeling is
forward
so you keep stable hips
stable forward
these are not wide not too close
to
stimulate both hands both hands should
look the same
not one dead and the other one alive
both the same not stiff
but full
full because if you're holding a you
know a melon in each hand
they're
it but they're not stiff
if for beginners um you can make them
do this it's good for their
stimulation their hands but
as you become more experienced just
full thinking about the points of the
wrist
okay
i hope this will help you develop your
tongue
get these parts right and you'll start
to release coke hue
in time
you
you can't pull people you get somebody
heavier than you
but you don't want to go into them and
let them take even more than they've got
that's why you go around this point
around this point and that when you
start to stable that's when you can
sort of dig in
and find your power
okay
so
don't give them anything
they grab
you stimulate
you shape
you don't waver it up and down
this stays where it is
stays when it is you go around it
you go around it you adjust the front
foot
and you either extend it forward or you
leave it where it is
showing you at this speed is uh almost
impossible to
just show you
yeah show you it um
as i'd like to
okay just check all your bits make sure
you feel okay
look at your hands
do your best
that's what we can do
thank you for your time